il ya plusieurs études scientifiques qui
confirme qu'il y aurait un lien entre la
consommation de cannabis et le
déclenchement de maladies mentales des
picots chez des gens qui n'en avaient
pas développé jusqu'à maintenant avec
nourrit l évêque mère d'un jeune homme
qui vit des psychoses à répétition
depuis qu'il a consommé du cannabis et
qui cherche à témoigner on a vu
aujourd'hui toute la journée des gens
festif à l'idée de l'égalisation pour
vous ces autres ça représente tout à
fait autre chose aujourd'hui
oui effectivement mais c'est sûr que je
vais pas dire que je suis totalement
contre la légalisation parce que
j'espère évidemment que il va y avoir
plus de recherche ce qui va être fait
j'espère que les taux de thc vont être
plus contrôlés que les jeunes vont être
mieux protégés bon c'est un souhait en
même temps si je vous parle de
de ce que mon fils passe par rapport à
à la légalisation ce qui réduit de son
côté dicton on lui dit que c'est mauvais
pour lui il dit maintenant ce n'est pas
mauvais pour moi il légaliserait pas la
substance si c'était mauvais pour ma
santé
et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes
qui résonne de cette manière là alors
une certaine banalisation un message en
tout cas oui mais par contre je constate
que du fait qu'on légalise s'amène ça
fait qu'on en parle beaucoup plus alors
je me dis qu'on va peut-être mieux
conscientiser les gens donc je pense
qu'il faut faire attention là il ya des
gens qui disent qu'il faut pas
dramatiser moi je dis prépare surtout
pas banaliser et expliquer aux gens
qu'il ya des risques reliés à la
consommation si on a évidemment des
d'autres facteurs de risque notre cadeau
de votre fils au 24 ans il consomme
depuis quatre cinq ans du cannabis et la
développer des picots oui puisque haut à
répétition quand on le soigne évidemment
de le faire entrer à l'hôpital
psychiatrique il ya une ordonnance de
traitement ça a pris beaucoup de temps
par contre avant que qui est un
reçoivent cette ordonnance là au début
il a essayé de prendre les médicaments
[ __ ] tout de suite ça tout de suite
enlevez tous les symptômes
et arrêtez de prendre les médicaments il
était correct qui lui ont dit ok on fait
on peut essayer d'arrêter à condition
que tu ne consomme plus et dès qu'ils
recommencent à consommer mais il repart
en psychose et là on est obligé de
refaire le processus et vous vous tester
avec lui dans le fond l'accueil du
système de santé en matière de santé
mentale les moyens qu'on vous donne à
vous parce que comme parent c'est
désespérant on voit la vie de son enfant
arrive dans la maladie mentale ya
souvent du déni ou si elle donne du
refus de traitement
comment que je regarde jetez vous
justement sur les ressources qu'on vous
donne le soutien qu'on vous donne qu'on
lui donne aussi je suis très critique
je vous dis que je suis très critique
parce que bon on fait ça fait une
tentative de suicide il ya au soudan
mode d'un toit une autre fois à chaque
fois qu'il ya eu des événements
dramatiques comme selon ses dires qui ça
y est ils vont le garder pour un certain
temps ils vont lui donner des outils
pour traiter pas juste les symptômes la
psychose mais aussi ce qui est sous
jacente parce que très souvent les gens
qui continuent à consommer il ya une
dépression en dessous il ya quelque
chose il ya des difficultés à
fonctionner et ce qu'on a constaté c'est
que malgré notre demande de son père et
moi et même de sa grand mère parce qu'il
réside en ce moment chez sa grand mère
paternelle notre demande à l'hôpital de
dire ben écoutez on n'est plus capable
d'assurer sa sécurité
pouvez-vous le garder mais on nous a dit
non on n'a pas les ressources qu'il faut
on ne peut pas assez d'argent un décor
qui sont beaucoup plus lourds
le sol gis de vote fils et si vous le
gardez pas bien on l'envoie dans un
centre de refuge pour sans abri alors
c'est sûr que moi la raison pour
laquelle je parle ces jours ci c'est
pour dénoncer cette situation là pour
demander aux élus de réinvestir en santé
mentale parce qu'il ya eu on le sait dès
beaucoup de coupures d'ailleurs c'est ce
que vous deux hôpitaux m'ont dit donc
les ressources et braquo graves comme
comme le veau là on dit que c'est pas si
grave y est pas encore à 6 quand tu fais
une psychose commence à se manifester
il commence à parler tout seul à rire
tout seul
il perd un peu le contact avec la
réalité donc on lui parle puis ça lui
prend un certain temps répondre façon
obligés de vérifier ce que tu m'as bien
entendu le viens de te dire qu'elle
était quelque chose à nous répète
puis peu à peu il commence à avoir des
comportements qui sont inadéquat comme
il a été violent il a été arrêté au mois
de juillet il ya passé cinq jours en
prison parce que il pour blaguer dit il
faisait part à des passants avec un
bâton il ya quelqu'un qui a porté
plainte les policiers l'ont trouvée avec
une autre personne qui s'était mis à le
frapper avec des bâtons utilisés et
finalement il était en train de se
bagarrer avec cette dame là partant donc
juste pour dire qu à quel point c'est un
comportement qui est normal et accepte
en effet rien à voir avec l'intelligence
de la personne n'a rien à voir avec le
guitariste intellectuelle qu'il est
conscient de sa maladie mais c'est qu'il
est difficile pour lui de l'accepter ou
de s'engager dans une voie de traitement
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit vraiment
conscient de sa maladie peut-être il peu
conscience campagne et pillé trading
on dirait qu'il devient conscient de sa
maladie mais c'est donc que ces nouveaux
là pourrait dire que ces nouveaux parce
que et mois déjà une zone et je dois oui
j'ai j'ai fait un psy cause dans le
passé mais maintenant c'est terminé
et quand je consomme c'est parce que ça
me fait du bien
puis l'heure des fois on dit oui mais là
ça va plus non non non ça va super bien
donc pour lui a pas de ya pas de lien de
cause à effet la danse at elle pour vous
il y en a deux la consommation est clair
les psychiatres on nous en parle à toute
la famille
donc mais comment lui faire comprendre
qu'il ya un lien de cause à effet
revendiquer plus d'investissements santé
mentale c'est important dans le réseau
hospitalier
j'ai parlé avec madame un malade de
l'équipe tantôt juste après vous si vous
avez une question ce serait quoi
comment faire pour l'amener à suivre un
traitement
c'est notre grand défi on a déjà on a
déjà voulu que ce soit imposé on nous
dit que c'est pas possible
non c'est sous la protection de la loi
des maladies mentales et très très
restreinte ou non vous au respect des
libertés
si la personne n'a pas conscience de ce
qui est bon pour elle c'est ma grande
question qu'est ce qu'on vous souhaite
bon courage votre fils ou si peu et oui
vous était calé en ce moment il est
les très très dépressif il parle de
suicide tous les jours donc si vous
voulez pas pu l'amener à l'urgence on le
garde quelques jours et puis on leur
emploi avec mercy bon courage